simplifica y nos piden hacer una resta
quieren que a 16 x + 14 le restemos 3x
cuadrada más x menos 9 muy bien esto es
básicamente hacer una suma solo que
teniendo el cuidado de que esté menos
primero tenemos que distribuirlo si
tenemos que distribuirlo en cada uno de
estos términos entonces hay que
multiplicar primero por menos uno o bien
pensar como que estamos sumando el
negativo entonces déjame reescribir la
expresión para hacer eso el primero no
cambia es más le voy a quitar le voy a
quitar el paréntesis le voy a poner 16 x
+ 14
y ahora sí debemos distribuir este signo
menos déjame tomar otro color entonces
primero va menos por este 3x cuadrada
nos quedaría menos 3x cuadrada luego
menos con este x menos menos 1 x x es
menos x menos por más es menos y
finalmente este menos por este menos 9
nos queda igual a más 9 menos uno por
menos 9 es igual a más 9 muy bien aquí
ya tenemos desarrollado con el signo
menos verdad y ahora lo que tenemos que
hacer es combinar los términos que
tengan el mismo exponente empezando por
el más alto para que quede en forma
estándar entonces creo que el exponente
más alto es cuadrado ajá es este de acá
y nada más tenemos este término déjame
indicarlo con este color rojo entonces
únicamente tenemos este término de acá
que nos quedaría lo ponemos por acá
menos 3 x al cuadrado muy bien ahora
vamos con los términos que tienen x a la
1 como este 16 x y este menos x los voy
a indicar en color rosa serían
eso es rosa
sería este de acá 16 x menos x
cuánto nos quedaría pues 16 menos 116
menos uno es igual a 15 entonces sería
más 15 x y finalmente tenemos que
combinar los términos constantes que
sería este de acá el 14 y este de acá el
99 más 14 23 entonces aquí le ponemos
más 23 y terminamos simplificando esta
expresión nos queda menos 3x cuadradas
más 15 x más 23